also wir haben wir so ein brötchen und
heute haben wir mal einen anderen
bahnhof köln messe deutz kennt da ja
vielleicht und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe um
eine rasend schnell lang geworden da
konnte ich mal wieder zum schlechtesten
friseurin meiner stadt gehen der spaß
ist hier das ist immer so die frage
nehme ich das jetzt an weil
wahrscheinlich sind von den seismisch
bestellung bei a das sieht doch gut aus
gerne ich mache das gerne nachts frau
damit ihr euch auch schon auf das video
freuen könnt und zwar habe ich hier ein
staubsauger roboter bestellt für 20 euro
glaube ich werden wir irgendwann diese
woche natürlich mal testen wärs wenn ihr
die videos feiert könnt ihr gerne jetzt
mal die kommentare schreiben hashtag so
genug gelagert jetzt kommen wir mal zum
thema was machen heute es gibt wieder
eine 24 stunden challenge ich habe mir
wieder einige ideen von euch durch
gelesen und bin zum entschluss gekommen
also das ist jetzt die planung für die
nächsten zwei wochen dieses video seht
ihr wahrscheinlich erst danach aber ich
pflege morgen nach italien ganz spontan
und dann von dort aus nach berlin auf
jeden fall sind in den nächsten sieben
tagen zwei flüge geplant also insgesamt
sogar vier flüge ich bin also viermal am
flughafen was bedeutet ich könnte ganz
easy x 24 stunden nur flughafen produkte
oder flughafen essen was auch immer das
kommt auf jeden fall dann nächste woche
und deswegen fangen wir heute mit 24
stunden nur bahnhof essen anders wurde
auch extrem oft vorgeschlagen ich hoffe
ihr könnt in meinem ideen raus jetzt
folgen
das machen wir heute ganz wichtig für
die trainees erstens wie teuer wird ist
ja das kann man ja dann vergleichen bahn
im flughafen beides relativ teuer was
ist eurer ich würde mal zu flughafen
tendieren das werden wir dann sehen und
wichtig auch was gesünder
ich würde auch mal sagen obwohl das ist
schwierig in köln gibt es natürlich
einmal den hauptbahnhof
es gibt dann aber auch noch andere
bahnhöfe ich würde sagen es trotzdem
erst mal zum hauptbahnhof und jetzt ist
gerade mittags übrigen
also bis zum nachmittag sogar schon na
ja ich will gar nicht lange lagern wir
fangen sofort mal an lassen doch nach
oben dafür weit und 24 stunden stellen
ist abonniert den kanal und vor allem
kommentiert eure ideen was soll ich
machen
dann war zum bahnhof metzger leute jetzt
wird es zum bahnhof und geben euch mal
mein outfit
also ich finde das sieht auf jeden fall
also ich würde sagen ist auf jeden fall
ein angebrachtes bahnhof outfit oder so
leute angefangen beim hauptbahnhof muss
sagen ich war ja schon ewig nicht mehr
ich bin voll überfordern weil hier gibt
es so viele gibt's musik in arco wand
übernahmen
ich hätte gern eine käse presse ein
comic bergleute wieder draußen
ich habe mir zum ersten mal in meinem
leben so pott geholt war das auch das
häufig alles zu tragen als ich will
möglichst viele verschiedene gesunde
sachen ausprobieren das problem ist wenn
man einmal da ist man kann ja gar nicht
soviel tragen
das ist mir erst aufgefallen als ich
auch da war leute wir haben jetzt
folgendes mittagessen einmal hier eine
käse brezel dann ein porridge ich weiß
nicht ob man das so mittags ist aber nah
sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus und dazu
eine banane kiwi ja irgendwas noch
schmutz muti da regt sich ja irgendwie
hier darüber aufwendig smoothie sage
obwohl ich finde das hört sich schon
richtig an
smoothy jetzt geht's erst mal zurück
heute abend kann ich dann nochmal jeden
fall eigentlich mit der band reicht und
heute abend auf jeden fall weil hätte
ich gerade eigentlich auch schon machen
können also wir sehen uns gleich zu
hause obwohl dieses probiere ich schon
mal sonst ist es gleich noch frisch bin
ich mal gespannt wie schmeckt eigentlich
echt nice wobei das glaube ich zum
frühstück wasser ist a ha den smoothie
habe ja schon probiert der ist wirklich
sehr sehr gesund hat auch vier euro 50
gekostet also ich bin jetzt van bommel
streich 50 smoothie 450 32 euro knapp
wir sind dann bei zehn euro nur für das
mittagessen leute naja wir dann später
haut rein
sollte das habe ich auch noch nie
gesehen diese feuerwehr fährt sogar lang
alle feuerwehrmänner steigen aus auf die
straße ziehen der hat ihre hosen
ansteigen wieder ein und fahren jetzt
weiter ist das normale leute
der abend ist so langsam in gang also es
ist schon relativ spät
ich hatte irgendwie die ganze zeit so im
kopf so ja ist ja bahnhof da ist ja
alles 24 stunden aufweist
aber das ist ja nicht so dass ist ja so
stumpf ich fahre einfach die ganze zeit
zum bahnhof und wieder zurück leute also
auf geht's mal wieder zum bahnhof ich
hoffe wir finden noch was weil wir haben
es wirklich schon 10 uhr was los so
leute dann wollen wir mal gucken was
noch offen hat
im bahnhof um 22.30 aber ich finde so
köln bei nacht zu der bahnhof von so das
ist schon wirklich mal richtig schön
auch wenn ich hier fast lieben das ist
so krass man wohnt in köln aber hier ist
man eigentlich fast die auch jetzt schon
geschlossen jetzt sehe ich auch passende
kleidung aus fähige ich habe jetzt auch
wirklich richtig hunger weil ich heute
mittag ja oder heute kurz nach mittag
seien visionär aber ich habe einfach
nicht so viel gegessen irgendwie
deswegen brauche ich jetzt was
kalorienhaltig ist ein scheiß jetzt ist
ja zu hier gab auch zu wir haben ja alle
um 22 uhr zugemacht
blöderweise wir gehen jetzt hier einfach
in sein restaurant oder schweinsteiger
ich glaube ich nehme hier schöne
currywurst jetzt vor sido lecker aus 180
120 oder 180 gramm 95 museen jetzt
wirklich
dann waren habe es auch nie so
wahrgenommen dass wir investoren weil
das video schon ganz genau
und da ist halt einfach der ausgaben
hätte ich das früher gewusst oder bahn
gefahren
soweit die currywurst ist da und marie
hat spaghetti sieht auf jeden fall ganz
lecker aus
so leute fertig brauchen wir noch zum
rewe gehen und was gesundes kaufen
hier werden nämlich für mich noch mehr
warum er sich am morgen leicht auch für
den blog hier wunderschönen guten morgen
ich mache gerade parallel auch im
zweiten block weil ich hatte ja schon
gesagt für mich jetzt den flughafen und
ich war mit der bahn das heißt ich muss
auch über den bahnhof und wir haben
jetzt gerade 39 oder so mein flieger
geht in zwei stunden und ich wollte mir
natürlich noch was zu frühstücken am
bahnhof gestern abend habe ich übrigens
für zwei personen wieder 20 euro bezahlt
also welchen märkten mal die hälfte dazu
sind zehn euro sind wir schon mal 20
euro
na gut es war vom restaurant am bahnhof
und ich fand es nicht mehr teuer das
erste mal okay bis wohnungen wir sehen
uns so leute angekommen am bahnhof jetzt
muss ich mir erst mal was zu frühstücken
holen
die bahn hat schon wieder verspätung das
kennen wir ja schon heute haben wir mal
einen anderen bahnhof köln messe deutz
scan daher vielleicht sieht schön aus
mal gucken was es hier so schön ist für
mich gibt
münchen
und dazu noch ein wasser als wir
viele leute
habe ich mir geholt und auf dem wasser
und wenn ich glück habe ich jetzt eine
verspätete bahnen damit ich nämlich
schon am flughafen hahn ein bisschen
video frei
fünf minuten später
moskau
soweit also angekommen
viel zeit mein brötchen zu essen das hat
übrigens vier euro 70 gekostet mit
wasser also wir haben hier so ein
brötchen auf jeden fall geht es um geld
man sehen wir zum anderen papier
übergang aller hat 2014 leute was geht
ab danke dass ihr bis hingeschaut habt
ich habe das video ist schon fertig
geschnitten und ich hab mal wieder kein
ende gemacht aber das war auch irgendwie
ein bisschen schwierig weil ich habe ja
zwei videos oder zwei blocks
gleichzeitig gemacht und dann musste
irgendwie auch mal die übersicht
behalten okay das gehört jetzt dazu das
gehört dazu das kam erst letztes video
wo ich den billigsten flug den ich
gefunden habe einfach mal ein buch
schreibt und dorthin geflogen bin wenn
er das noch nicht gesehen habt schaut
euch das auf jeden fall ihr nach an
trotzdem muss ich jetzt noch mal ein
paar sachen zu dem video sagen was wir
jetzt gerade heute gesehen habt also das
bahnhofs experiment nicht wieso ich
hab's euch ja schon eingeblendet ich
habe für drei mahlzeiten 26 eur 19
gezahlt also hörten halten frühstück
mittagessen und abendessen das
abendessen war das meiste wird schon mal
sagen gut natürlich ist eine currywurst
jetzt nicht so das gesündeste trotzdem
hatte ich halt an dem tag einfach viel
zu wenig gegessen deswegen habe ich das
einfach mal genommen und ja 26 euro ich
weiß ihr könnt gerne meine kommentare
schreiben hätte das gedacht hätte
gedacht das ist weniger als kommt
natürlich auch immer ungefähr darauf an
was man was man sich jetzt ruhig zu
essen aber ich habe ja so viel geholt
dass ich ganz entspannt den tag über sat
geblieben bin ich freue mich jetzt auf
morgen bei morgen geht es los nach
berlin da fliege ich nach berlin für
zwei tage und dann mache ich dann mal
dass flughafen experiment mal gucken wie
teuer ist da würd ich halt mich dann
aber natürlich auch an vorgaben sowie in
diesem video das ich zum beispiel als
frühstück der hand ein brötchen vom
bäcker geholt habt mittags auch
irgendwie kleinigkeiten und abends dann
in einem restaurant gegessen habt also
bahnhofsrestaurant oder
flughafenrestaurant kommt ja darauf an
so dass man das auch gut vergleichen
kann ihr könnt jetzt schon mal sehr sehr
gerne in die kommentare schreiben was
glaubt ihr die 24 stunden flughafen
challenge wird die teurer
oder wird die günstiger denke ich nicht
eventuell aber gleich ich würde eher zu
teurer tendieren
ihr könnt eure meinung in die kommentare
schreiben bin ich mal gespannt lese ich
mir vorher gerne war durch ansonsten was
ist mit dem video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen das noch nach oben da meinen
instagram account ab 30 alexy und
schreibt weitere ideen in die kommentare
für weitere 24 stunden stellendes die
immer recht unterhaltsam sind um mir
eine menge spaß machen
ich bin gespannt das was wir sehen uns
mal wieder gibt's neues video mainz nur
hard rain